Does the right machine kill cancer directly or does it just stimulate the immune system to help your body kill cancer?
Well, that's a matter of debate. Personally, I think it kills cancer directly. Royal right
believed it killed cancer directly. I think anything that you hit with its own frequency is going to cause
that thing to vibrate. Whether it's light frequency or sound frequency, that would happen.
That's why you could take two to the 2D forks of the same frequency. It's a take a 528 2D pork,
and it is not vibrating. Take another one, hit it, vibrate it, put it near the other 2D pork,
without even touching it, and you'll cause the other 2D pork. There wasn't vibrating to vibrate.
Anything you hit with its own frequency will vibrate. Now that itself can kill cancer cells.
Cancer cells are already highly oxidatively stressed. They're already at the verge of death,
and they're continuing to replicate. That's why all nutritional cancer therapies are stimulating a
greater oxidative stress alternative cancer therapies, as well as standards of care. Cancer
therapies, chemotherapy is causing a greater oxidative stress. That's why it's killing cancer. The right
machine doesn't cause oxidative stress, but it causes that vibration. In a sense, it can physically
destroy the cancer. In the second sense, it will help physically break down the waste layer that
surrounds the growing highly metabolic cell structure that can hinder your immune system's ability
to get at it. In a sense, when you bring frequency back to a cell, you can stop it from replicating.
So, the right works in multiple different areas. There's probably about 20 different theories
on how the right works with cancer. Those, I think, are the main ones that I just commented. Does
it stimulate the immune system to help kill the cancer? Well, it aids the immune system to help kill
the cancer, but I do think it helps kill the cancer directly. I don't think one can really argue with
that. What do you see? I mean, people have argued, oh, I just think that's antidotal evidence.
Biodamity research that shows that, well, there is research coming out that vibration that frequencies
do kill pathogens. And there, you can't argue with, you know, some people have said, well, it's just
placebo medicine. People just think it's going to work. That's why it works. First of all, if that
was the case, I don't care if I think something's going to work and it works. All I care is that
something worked. Secondly, when people have used it on their animals, I don't think there's any
placebo evidence going on, but you can cat your cat can say, oh, kitty, come here. We're going to do
this on for your kitty cancer. The event said you only have a few weeks to live, but we're going to
run the kitty cancer frequency on you and see how you work. And the cat believes you and gets better
from their kitty cancer. That's just nonsense. So when we have dozens and dozens of antidotal
evidence that it works on children or animals that don't have a conscious placebo effect going on,
you can't argue with its efficacy. So there's probably other reasons on how frequencies work to help
kill cancer and kill pathogens that we have yet to discover. Unfortunately, you're not going to get
these huge research studies behind it because those cost, you know, millions of dollars and nobody's
funding those things. Secondly, even if you could get some rich person to fund a study like that,
you won't get it passed. You have to get a, you know, you have to in order to be a legal research study,
it has to go through the department of health to get qualifications to get these different
NRB numbers and all this stuff to do a research study and they'll never pass something like that.
So maybe out of our country, you could get a research study. But then again, people just will
pull through the research study. It's going to make a difference. So again, I'd be more interested
than it just works for people that's all I care. Instead of trying to get funding to prove it,
to a population that is don't radically position against anything other than what makes them money.
So all I care is that it works.